قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
ان الولايات المتحده تقف مع اسرائيل لضمان
امن حدودها الشماليه وتدعمها في التوصل
الى حلول دبلوماسيه واوضح انه تم الاتفاق
على دخول بعثه امميه الى شمال غزه لاعداد
تقيييم سيحدد ما يجب فعله للسماح للنازحين
الفلسطينيين بالعوده الى
هناك بينما تتجه حمله اسرائيل نحو مرحله
اقل ده في شمال غزه وبينما يقلص جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي عدد قواته هناك اتفقنا
على اعداد مخطط يسمح للامم المتحده
بالقيام بمهمه تقييم ستحدد ماذا يجب فعله
للسماح للنازحين الفلسطينيين بالعوده الى
بيوتهم في شمال غزه هذا لن يحدث بين عشيه
وضحاها لان هناك تحديات كبيره امنيا
وانسانيا واخرى تتعلق بالبنيه التحتيه لكن
بعثه الامم المتحده دا عمليه تقدير هذه
العوائق وكيف يمكن تجاوزها وفي اجتماعات
اليوم كنت واضحا ايضا يجب ان يتمكن
المدنيون الفلسطينيون من العوده الى
ديارهم بمجرد ما تسمح الظروف بذلك ويجب ان
لا يتم الضغط عليهم لمغادره
غزه